the opening scene is set in New York
City where we are introduced to a young
boy named Milo he is confined to a
wheelchair but despite this he dreams of
becoming an astrophysicist
simultaneously on a farm in Missouri a
man named Ricky is talking to his friend
on the phone he doesn't notice that an
aircraft lands near his house after
which he loses the signal on his device
the signal disruption extends Beyond
Missouri becoming a global issue soon
after an airplane lands amidst the heart
of New York City with the sky shrouding
in fog and a fleet of enormous
spacecraft blocking the sun in the face
of this bizarre occurrence military
forces prepare for Action while citizens
descend into Panic the news reporters
speculate an invasion yet the identity
and intentions of these newcomers remain
uncertain in a surprising turn of events
the people are visited by their deceased
loved ones who introduce themselves as
Caroline the alien alien supervisor for
Earth government officials label them as
overlords they all convey the same
message that they're here to help the
earthlings and to put an end to
suffering hunger and sickness they claim
that they're not the conquerors but the
driving force that will help Humanity
change probably by killing it they
assure that everything will be the same
except for one thing Injustice according
to them a new version of Earth known as
utopia will be the new law of the land
in the ensuing days the world begins to
undergo a transformation just as the
aliens promised warring people like
Arabs and Jews come together in harmony
a government meeting reveals that the
wars in the Congo Sudan and Korea which
could not stop for years have ended one
evening Ricky and his girlfriend Ali are
preparing for bed when all the
electronic devices in their home go
Haywire the residence starts to tremble
so Ricky Ellie and their Dog Retreat
down to the basement soon after a
mysterious to light coming from a Droid
slowly dismantles their house forcing
Ricky to step outside the spacecraft
opens its door inviting him inside Ricky
agrees to get in on the condition that
they leave his family alone in response
the Droid restores his house to its
original state and Ricky boards the
craft to fly away elsewhere the military
checkpoints closed the area over which
the spaceship is hovering however a
crowd of sick and crippled people try to
make their way to the restricted area
amidst this a woman steps forward with
her sick child and lifts the crying baby
up towards the sky please take him I
don't want him in the next scene Ricky
finds himself at the Four Seasons Hotel
in New York City he recognizes the hotel
as it's the same place where he and his
late wife Annabelle had celebrated their
honeymoon in the past before long a
disembodied voice introduces himself as
Carolyn and proposes that Ricky serve as
a liaison between the overlord and
Earth's inhabitants confused and
hesitant Ricky suggests that someone
with more political influence should be
chosen for this role however the voice
mentions that Ricky is the most suitable
candidate due to his honesty
trustworthiness and because his name
will remind everyone of Trailer Park
Boys which always brings a smile the
alien also provides him with a shiny
device whose design is futuristic but
its purpose is unknown meanwhile the
government officials learn of Ricky's
abduction so a U.S secret agent named
Paul danlow decides to visit Ricky's
Farmhouse for additional information by
the time he reaches it several news
reporters surround the area to cover the
event coincidentally at the same moment
the Droid drops Ricky off and departs
following this Paul summons Ricky for a
private conversation during which he
demands the surrender of the shiny
device when Ricky resists Paul holds him
at gunpoint leaving our guy with no
choice but to comply however as Ricky
proceeds to hand over the device he
opens its lid activating some sort of
unknown Force as a consequence the
crying baby from earlier mysteriously
gets healed hours later similar reports
come from around the world as various
diseases even the incurable ones are
inexplicably cured college students
everywhere are free of chlamydia
afterwards Ricky is summoned to the
White House for a press conference Barry
tries to take things slowly by
introducing himself as a mediator
between the overlords and Earth's
inhabitants however the situation
quickly spirals out of control as
reporters press for more information
about the aliens they pose numerous
inquiries about carellen's appearance
and the contents of the Droid none of
which Ricky can answer all he can say
for certain is that those things they
just showed off in Mexico are fake as
in the next meeting Ricky asks
Carolyn to reveal himself but the latter
claims that the world is not ready to
see him yet as the days pass by Ricky is
summoned to numerous meetings to
deliberate on the future of Earth the
information discussed in these meetings
is then relayed to the public through
conferences ambitious agendas are set
including the eradication of poverty
disease and the maintenance of Global
Peace in the midst of these developments
Ellie discovers that Annabelle had
visited Ricky earlier in the Four
Seasons Hotel holds sentimental value as
their honeymoon suite this Revelation
understandably saddens her but despite
her feelings she assures Ricky of her
unwavering support in just six months
the overlords with Ricky's assistance
successfully eliminate Warfare hunger
and poverty from the world they got a
long way to go before they get rid of
stupidity though however there remains a
faction of humans who are hesitant to
trust the aliens suspecting ulterior
motives such as an invasion a resistance
movement known as the freedom League
funded by media Tycoon Hugo Wainwright
is gaining a lot of followers they start
spreading doubt in carellen's patronage
filling the streets with protests Ricky
conveys this information to Carolyn and
again tries to persuade him to reveal
himself he claims that it will Foster
trust but the alien continues to decline
such requests but what if they'll laugh
at my nose says Carolyn on the other
hand Milo is constantly dedicating
himself to Gathering the information
about the aliens and is trying to figure
out how their Arrow Works he uses his
extraordinary intelligence to write an
essay about the same that earns him a
complete scholarship in a new school
according to his research the overlords
are 30 000 years ahead of earthlings one
evening Milo Witnesses his mother making
a purchase from a local dealer and
expressing dissatisfaction with the
quality of the goods when she requests a
refund the dealer slaps her and busts
out a firearm Milo intervenes and
confronts the dealer leading into a
heated argument as a result of this the
dealer shoots Milo in the chest killing
him instant but just a few seconds later
a beam of light descends from the sky
emitting a mysterious force it
instantaneously kills the dealer and
miraculously revives Milo not only is
Milo brought back to life but he also
gains the ability to walk back in
Missouri Ricky and Ellie are having
dinner when the latter candidly
expresses her discontent with what's
going on she believes that the aliens
are playing with his mind and this is
why they aren't allowing him to move on
from his past thus she attempts to
persuade him not to continue working for
the overlords but despite her concerns
Ricky insists that it's his
responsibility as he sees himself
working for the betterment of the entire
world in addition Ellie is also sad as
they are unable to have children despite
their best attempts the reason for this
is unknown however their conversation is
abruptly disrupted by their dogs barking
Ricky steps outside to check only to be
unexpectedly knocked out by some people
a short while later he regains his
Consciousness and finds out that he has
been abducted by the freedom League
militants Ricky is then taken to a
remote base supervised by Hugo upon
arriving at the massive underground
bunker Hugo proposes that they regain
control from the overlords by destroying
the positive changes they've brought to
humanity he also asks Ricky to join the
freedom league is their free beer no
sounds like garbage unbeknownst to him
carellen is broadcasting their entire
communication to the public Ricky
refuses to participate in such an awful
plan which enrages Hugo on his order the
League members pull out their guns and
shoot towards him but just moments
before the bullets can reach him the
overlords freeze time around Ricky and
terminate the broadcast at that moment a
door opens and Annabelle appears calling
Ricky inside however he asks her not to
come to him again because he has already
buried her memory and wants to move on
shortly after Ricky's dropped back at
his Farmhouse safe and sound the
following day he attends another meeting
with Carolyn during which the alien
figure behind the mirror informs him
that the freedom league is disbanding
Carolyn anticipates that the states will
soon unite and people will live happily
ever after he thanks Ricky for his
service and indicates that his
assistance is no longer needed just
before Ricky is sent back he manages to
capture a photograph of the mirror
behind which carellen always hides Upon
returning home he reviews the image with
Ellie and they understand the reason why
Carolyn wanted to keep himself hidden
now that Ricky is free from his work he
decides to begin a new chapter of his
life and proposes to Ellie for marriage
the scene then fast forwards 15 years
revealing that Milo has now graduated
from MIT and works as an astrophysicist
at the World Federation a new Unified
Government on Earth the present world is
completely different as compared to the
past as the aliens have successfully
achieved achieved their goals now
Carolyn finally decides to reveal
himself to the general public for this a
huge event is prepared at a stadium and
the people appear very excited to meet
their Guardian Angel not long after a
giant spaceship lands on the stadium and
two kids enter to escort Carolyn out
much to everyone's shock carellen looks
exactly like a Devil complete with horns
Wings red skin and a tail and a bare
cherubic ass the scene then cuts to four
years later and it's now the year 2035
the golden age has indeed arrived for
mankind as inequality crime and War are
all gone people have renewable green
energy and enough food for the entire
planet earth has become a paradise and
the humans are living healthy lives
despite these overwhelmingly positive
changes Milo for some reason is worried
about the future moreover he is laid off
from his astrophysics post as all space
research programs are being terminated
it but before he leaves for South Africa
Milo makes sure to pocket a few hard
drives worth of data on the overlords
because nobody knows anything about them
yet one night Ricky is awakened by a
beam of light outside his residence this
time he understands that it's karelin so
he follows the light to his Tool Shed
Carolyn apologizes to Ricky before
confessing some big news the Earth has a
new Destiny a short while later Ellie
walks out in search of her husband only
to notice the Droid flying off she asks
Ricky about the matter but the latter
hides the truth and claims that karellan
simply came to check on them in the next
scene we are shown a large research
facility in South Africa that is managed
by a health practitioner named Dr Rupert
Boyce this facility happens to be the
same place where Milo currently works
with a colleague named Rachel one day
the entire facility starts to shake
appearing as if it's an earthquake
Rachel notices all their animals
panicking in their cages after a while
Dr voice finds an additional chamber on
the facility's ground floor seemingly
created by a car Allen inside there is a
glowing communication device that looks
like a large Ouija board Dr Boyce
interprets this discovery as a signal
that car Ellen wants them to establish
contact with someone astonished Dr Boyce
says ghosts are real too later on
Milo seeks out doctor Boyce and
expresses his growing unease regarding
the actions of the overlords he mentions
witnessing unusual behavior among the
wild animals in the lab however Dr Boyce
dismisses his concern as he seems to
have something different in his mind he
guides Milo to a room filled with
figurines of animals where he discloses
that he has been assisting the overlords
in capturing various species of animals
and sending them to an alien planet
according to him only one species is
missing from their collection Homo
sapiens Dr Boyce hopes that the
overlords will take him to their planet
on the same night the overlords pay a
visit to the Gregson family consisting
of the father Jake the mother Amy and
their son Tommy Little Tommy Greggs the
Droid emits its mysterious light Force
onto Amy and Tommy causing them to
experience restlessness in their sleep
afterwards the the craft departs
Awakening Tommy Jake overhears his wife
murmuring about saving their children in
her sleep hence becomes concerned he
wakes her up before going to check on
Tommy Jake finds his son in the garage
who is acting in a strange manner when
he tries to approach him the young boy
forcefully shoves him against the wall
the following day Jake shares the
incident with his wife and also points
out Tommy's recent bizarre behavior Amy
doesn't believe in his words but when he
insists they take Tommy to a counselor
named Paretta during their initial
session Tommy confides in Paretta about
apocalyptic Visions he has been
experiencing he describes being taken by
the overlords to a dark hot place where
a large eye blocks out the sun you're
just describing Lord of the Rings Tommy
says Paretta as peretta begins to ask
too many questions the voices in Tommy's
head become increasingly chaotic leaving
him deeply Disturbed he covers his ears
and abruptly exits the room sending his
parents into a state of panic meanwhile
an invisible force tightens around the
crucifix hanging from peretta's neck
causing her to choke but before she can
be killed she manages to remove the
chain Tommy then touches his mother's
belly and tells her that the baby has
stopped crying this leaves Amy
bewildered as she isn't pregnant
following this unsettling encounter
peretta advises Jake to stay safe before
leaving the house visibly distressed
meanwhile in Missouri a group of people
surround Ricky's Farmhouse with the
intention of gathering info about the
overlords witnessing their presence
Ricky steps outside to confront them
however at the same time his veins begin
to swell and turn a crimson Hue causing
him to collapse on the ground following
this Ricky is rushed to a hospital where
the doctor delivers a grim prognosis it
appears that carellen has poisoned him
with some substance which explains his
earlier apology upon learning of her
husband's limited time left to live
Ellie returns home and activates all
electronic devices in an attempt to talk
to karelin but her efforts prove futile
his cherubass doesn't show the next day
Paretta goes to see a church pastor
although the church has been long
abandoned he diligently maintains the
premises peretta recounts the recent
events at Tommy's home and shows her
chain as evidence in response the pastor
speculates that the overlords are
similar to demons from hell targeting
those humans who still hold faith in God
despite these dire circumstances he
encourages peretta not to lose hope four
months later Jake and Amy receive an
astounding Revelation Amy is pregnant
something which their son knew a long
time ago despite the shock they enjoy
the good news and Amy starts considering
names for their upcoming baby after a
while of deliberation she comes up with
a name Jennifer strangely enough Tommy
knows the name before Amy can reveal it
one evening peretta visits the Gregson
family's residence to offer her prayers
during her visit the alien Droid appears
directly above their house projecting a
beam of light peretta raises her damaged
crucifix towards the Droid prompting it
to depart following this she rushes to
check on the family finding them
unharmed she attempts to warn them about
the evil nature of the overlords but the
family doesn't believe in her claims
later that night peretta learns of
Ricky's illness through the news and
decides to visit his Farmhouse upon her
arrival she meets with Ellie and tries
to befriend her in the meantime Dr Boyce
prepares a special party event at his
office building he sends one of his
employees Morton to California in order
to invite the Gregson family on the
pretense of interviewing Jake for a job
unbeknownst to the gregsons Dr Boyce is
following the strict orders of Carolyn
who is now after the family Jake
initially hesitates to accept the
invitation but he eventually agrees due
to Amy's insistence the scene then cuts
to the night of the party where a grand
hall is packed with the dressed up
people including Milo and Rachel the
Gregson family arrives and meets with Dr
Boyce shortly after Tommy is escorted to
an entertainment room while Dr Boyce
offers to show Amy around the premises
Jake coincidentally meets Milo and the
two engage in conversation surprisingly
the latter reveals that the organization
is shutting down and no recruitment is
taking place sensing that something is
amiss Jake shares this information with
his wife before going to find his son
just then Carolyn the guest of honor for
the evening makes his entrance at the
party venue he ascends the stage and
informs the attendees that with Mr
Boyce's assistance he has been sending
different species of animals to his home
planet to establish a zoo after a brief
speech Carolyn instructs Dr Boyce to
bring Amy to the room with the Ouija
board for a private talk once there
Carolyn has Amy's hand on the board
which enables him to communicate with
the unborn baby inside her her he then
transmits the messages to the skies via
a mysterious beam of light unable to
comprehend what's happening Dr Boyce
tries to extricate Amy from corellin's
grasp but she unexpectedly hurls him
across the room meanwhile Jake locates
Tommy but the boy's mind appears to be
under the control of someone else as
Jake approaches his son he is forcefully
pushed against the wall subsequently
Tommy runs towards the roof and jumps
off but instead of falling to the ground
he manages to hover just a few feet
above it avoiding a potentially fatal
impact with this experimentation Carolyn
announces that Amy's job is done she and
Tommy then return to their normal state
of mind and Jake hastily takes them back
home on their way Amy experiences an
immense pain in her stomach causing her
to be rushed to the hospital on the
other hand Milo who has been observing
the light beam deduces the purpose
behind Carolyn's actions Carolyn was
using Amy and the Ouija board to
transmit a message in his native
language to Interstellar receptors later
Milo accompanied by Rachel returns to
his place and initiates some research
after an entire night of diligent work
he learns that the symbol Caroline was
broadcasting in the sky was the
constellation Karina the overlord's
Homeworld thrilled by the discovery the
two end up sharing a romantic kiss and
Milo gets his first half chub in the
next scene Caroline travels back to
Missouri to pay Ricky and Ellie a very
important visit he presents them with a
vial of medicine claiming that it
possesses the power to completely heal
Ricky shortly after peretta bursts into
the scene and accuses corellen of
deceiving Humanity this makes karelin
confess that it wasn't Ricky's illness
that had caused his sterility but rather
it was his own doing he justifies his
actions as an act of kindness because
the Earth's days are numbered according
to corellin those with children will
face significant hardship in the near
future so he chose to spare Ricky from
such suffering despite the explanation
peretta grabs a shotgun and fires that
corellin killing him on the spot this
makes her feel that the world's problems
are finally over however a guilt-ridden
Ricky suddenly Springs into action and
administers the vial of miraculous
medicine to karelin Reviving him from
the brink of death and with his second
life karelin tells a crying Pareto that
her faith and religion is good but still
in vain because no one can prevent
what's coming a i later that night
Paretta sees the spirit of her mother
and follows it until she falls from a
balcony resulting in her tragic demise
simultaneously at the hospital Amy gives
birth to the baby girl Jennifer whose
eyes emit A peculiar and Vivid Green
Glow the scene fast forwards to four
years later and now the children are
stronger than previous generations with
telekinetic and psychic abilities Milo
who is dating Rachel wonders how the
future Generations will be back in
Missouri Ricky is still dealing with the
effects of his illness and he attempts
to implant small chip-like devices into
his arms later he is visited by kareline
in his backyard where the alien informs
him that the final stage has begun in
the next scene Milo and Rachel are
strolling through the park when they
spot a girl raising her hands towards
the sky and chanting out Jennifer's name
not only in the park but kids all around
the world are following suit some of the
kids even show up at the gregson's
doorstep looking for their leader it
appears that only Jennifer has the power
to show them worlds beyond Earth seeing
this unusual phenomena Jake and Amy
decide to relocate to New Athens where
the humans still follow the old way of
life as they drive out of their place a
number of children block their path but
Jennifer effortlessly moves them aside
with her extraordinary abilities taking
the parents of back it's like the story
of Moses but way freaking weirder as all
of this is happening Milo learns that
all the kids are connected to Jennifer
in order to find more information he
tries to reach Jake but the latter
ignores his calls as he wants his
children to live a normal life as the
gregsons make it to New Athens they
learn that the city fits the time before
the overlords arrived the city is
polluted smelly overcrowded and death is
always lingering in an alley somewhere
ah Paradise shortly after the family is
welcomed by the city's mayor Jerry Hall
cross the mayor tells them that they
don't have to worry because New Athens
is completely different from Utopia he
then gives them a special tour before
taking them to their new home at their
new residence Jake receives a call from
Milo one more time this time on Amy's
suggestion he agrees to answer the call
Milo requests permission to talk to
Jennifer to which and he agrees Milo
then asks Jennifer to look into a mirror
and share her visions of the chair in
response the girl asks him to come
closer after which she shares a grim
vision of the Earth being engulfed in
flames the vision is so powerful that it
destroys the communication device
startling Milo Jennifer then announces a
chilling message the end begins
determined to protect the Earth Milo
decides to sneak onto the overlord's
spacecraft with an intention to get to
their home World his beloved Rachel
disagrees with his idea but Milo
convinces her assuring that he'll return
following this the pair sneaks into the
shipment truck and Rachel with a heavy
heart places him in a vacuum-sealed bag
just like the other animals she kisses
him goodbye before letting him sleep in
the bag Milo is then transported onto
the spaceship and the ship departs in
The Farmhouse Ricky is presently
experiencing intense pain as the small
chip-like devices don't help him anymore
did they ever Ellie tries to sue them
but Ricky Cries Out Annabelle's name
leaving Ellie devastating it at this
point Ricky is teleported back in time
and finds himself in the Four Seasons
Hotel there he begins dwelling via his
old reminiscences but he soon realizes
that it's just his obsession Carolyn who
is also present there offers to bring
her back and slow down the time for him
so that he can spend more with her
however Ricky refuses because it's not
real I mean you're you're in The Matrix
talking to an alien is any of this real
he then makes a bold decision and asks
karelin to bury the room deleting the
memories once and for all that night
Ricky steps outside the house and lays
down in the yard gazing up at the sky
Ellie joins him and Ricky confesses his
love for her as they talk he slowly
passes out and succumbs to his illness
on the other hand the Gregson family is
enjoying an old movie in a cinema Hall
when carellen suddenly appears on the
screen he addresses the people of Earth
One Last Time claiming that the Golden
Age coming to an end he also informs
them that the children will all leave
the Earth to become superhumans and no
more of them will be born the adults
will have to live out their Century in
peace Paving the way for a new species
at this moment a pregnant woman in the
hospital freaks out as her baby has gone
missing following this Jennifer begins
to float in the air and moves Towards
the Sky followed by all the other
children on the planet the parents
cannot believe what is happening and
they cry out in the pain of Separation
Jake and Amy hold their son and plead
with him to stay which the boy complies
with the three remaining gregsons then
go in search of the mayor Jerry
eventually they find him at the church
in the cemetery where his daughter is
buried he has a time bomb beside him as
he is on the verge of blowing up the
entire New Athens Jerry expresses that
there was hope when their children were
on Earth but now there is no reason to
live Jake encourages him not to lose
hope and to keep fighting but the mayor
doesn't listen while they talk Amy
realizes that Tommy is missing and goes
out to find him when she locates him
Tommy informs her that his extra time on
Earth has ended and he must join the
rest of the children Amy can't stop her
son and watches him Ascend into the sky
with a heavy heart with both of their
children now absent from their lives Amy
rejoins Jake amidst his argument with
Jerry she attempts to soothe Jake by
reminiscing about their past about how
they met and fell in love the couple
then holds hands and the bomb detonates
engulfing the entire city meanwhile
Jennifer stands atop a hill Gathering
energy into a radiant light and sending
it into the sky in the overlord
spacecraft Milo struggles for breath and
gets himself out of the bag he hurriedly
reaches for his medicine and injects it
into his body once he stabilizes he is
welcomed by an alien named vindarten
vendarten informs him that 40 years have
passed on Earth revealing that they are
on the sixth planet in the Karina system
Milo inquires about the condition of
Earth and vendarten shows a darkish
planet which is full of lava the alien
then reveals that the Earth's future was
planned Millennia Ago by the overmind
the Supreme Creator furthermore he
explains that they simply travel to
planets designated by the overmind and
carry out his instructions to alter them
after hearing all of this Milo requests
permission to meet the overmind driven
by his desire to understand everything
he is then teleported to a white space
where he finds an orange shadow that
represents the over mind in order to
help Milo feel secure it takes the form
of Rachel and explains that the children
are Divine and they can only become part
of the whole when Milo asks if humanity
is over he sees reflections of Rachel
and becomes lost in intense light when
he wakes up 85 years have already passed
and Earth is now abandoned with all of
humanity having died out leaving him as
the last human being nevertheless the
overlords who wanted to help Milo
present him with an aged frozen corpse
of Rachel devastated Milo pulls out the
necklace from the body shattering it
into pieces carellen consoles The
Grieving Milo and assures him that
Rachel continues to exist as a figment
in Milo's mind the alien generously
offers Milo to live the rest of his days
on the overlord's craft however he
volunteers to return to Earth and report
back his findings as a scientist upon
his return to Earth Milo sits in the
middle of a ruined City on an old couch
he documents everything and sends the
information to the overlords he reflects
on his life from its very Inception and
implores Caroline to preserve something
from the planet to ensure Humanity's
enduring memory shortly after Milo finds
Jennifer the last remaining child
Gathering energy from what's left of the
Earth the ground beneath Milo begins to
crumble and fear grips him in the final
scene Milo begs the overlords to at
least Safeguard a Memento in response
they play him his memories allowing him
to retrieve his life sounds visions and
feelings and for that brief moment right
before the world explodes Milo goes back
to a simpler time a world without Utopia
finally the planet erupts into countless
fiery fragments while the overlords Fly
Away subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching